what is going on everybody welcome to
the second how to build a quadcopter
tutorial video in this video we're going
to talking about all the supplies and
decisions and choices and all that
exciting stuff that you're gonna have to
make in order to build a quad first
things first I'm going to be assuming
you guys are building a 250 but it
really doesn't matter from this point
forward some of the power of the motor
and the ESC in the battery and all that
changes as you get bigger but for the
most part the types of supplies you need
are all the same every quadcopter breaks
down into the same types of parts you
need some motors you need ESC s which
are kind of buried in here but I'll show
you some in a minute I mean Motors es es
obviously some propellers some sort of
frame some sort of flight controller
which basically accepts the transmitters
signals and also does balancing and
stuff like that obviously a receiver to
receive those signals and it feeds them
into the control board the control board
then sends out those signals to the ESC
S which then tell the motors how fast to
spin basically so then so those are like
the main parts that you need ok from
there you have a basically you require a
battery I put the battery on the bottom
but a lot of people put the battery
actually in here if you do put a battery
on the bottom just for the record make
sure you can land and have like landing
gear that is taller than the battery you
don't bounce it on your battery the
battery for the record a lipo battery is
highly flammable and so what happens is
first of all just another thing since
we're talking about batteries if a lipo
battery over discharges it has the
propensity to expand and so for example
this is a an iPod that was left in my
drawer for I don't know years and you
can see that it looks like an airbag
deployed actually that's a lipo battery
and what's happened is it got over
discharge and expanding if I then took a
screw and like hammered the screw in
there or nail or whatever this would
likely erupt in very violent flames okay
so that's lipo batteries for you so it's
important that you don't over discharge
your lipo battery but also that you just
don't go puncturing lipo batteries
that's a recipe for a problem
um one thing I'll show you grab one of
these so here's a battery this is a lipo
battery this is a venom flight pack 2111
point one volts
I recommend the battery right now I
would not buy the 2100 this is the older
model get the 2200 with the universal
adapter we'll talk about that a little
bit here but by that but anyway this is
a low voltage warning some control
boards will come with one but if it
doesn't I highly recommend you get one
what it does is it plugs into the
battery and it tells you the voltage of
the battery of its entire battery and
then also the voltage per cell in the
battery and then as it gets below a
certain point an alarm will go off and
tell you that you need to bring in your
quadcopter and charge it that way you
don't over discharge the battery and
create a fire hazard and all that so I
recommend that on the topic of batteries
to basically when you go and buy let's
say you buy a quadcopter kit there it's
going to come with a lot of times it'll
just be the frame the es es and the
motors but then you can find some kits
that come with the frame the EEOC's the
motors the control board power
distribution board they come visit
everything you need except a battery
some sort of battery charger this is
what I used to charge balanced discharge
my batteries this is at energy tb6 beat
some nice high quality charger I
recommend you do
um not cheap out on your charger but it
has like a fast charge balance typical
charge and a discharge and you can save
various profiles in there for your
batteries anyway highly recommended this
charger so you know battery quality is
really important and in taking care of
your batteries is important so that it
won't come at the battery won't come to
the charger it won't come with a
receiver and it won't come with a
transmitter so this is my transmitter
this is a FST h9s fly sky th9 x
controller or transmitter router and
this one's a pretty high quality
controller it costs basically just as
much as the entire quad so you don't
have to spend so much money on the
controller I like this one it's got
various profiles you can program stuff
and you can fly just about
thing with it but really for any
quadcopter you just need these two
sticks that's it so find a control that
has those two sticks and you're good to
go okay you don't need to spend too much
money on this and all honesty so there's
that so the that's kind of like all the
essentials that you'll need now you can
you can buy the es skis and motors
separate the frame separate the control
board separate and all that or you can
get them together it just depends on the
prices at the time so in the description
I'll put a list of supplies that you
need and some suggestion some some
suggested kits and all that but at any
given time the prices are going to
fluctuate and change and all that if you
want to support the channel you can use
those links their Amazon affiliate links
but if you find like a better price
somewhere else or whatever by all means
go there and save yourself some money so
generally at least for me what I found
is see like the motors and ESC s cost
about 65 to 75 dollars but you can find
kits that are the motors ESC and frame
and sometimes some other stuff for like
$85 or $80 so I usually buy it leaves
those together and if you can buy like
the whole kit with everything else that
you need go for it
so now we're going to talk about is the
control board so this is one example of
a controller and this is another flight
controller these are two totally
different ones as you can see this one
is mounted like diagonal is shaped like
a diamond almost because the control
board what it has as much of gyros on it
and it not only it take does it take
signals from your receiver or yeah
basically so your receiver takes your
signal from the transmitter the receiver
sends the signal into here and this says
a signal out not only does it take the
signal from your transmitter basically
it also has gyros on it and to help
balance the board so like if a gust of
wind pushes your quad this way real
quick the quad will just automatically
stabilize itself you want to actually
have to do that so that's one example of
what the control board does for you but
as you can see this one so it wants to
go this way which works on some quads
but not other quads what I found is most
quads actually want they have holes
punched for the flight board to actually
be a square flight
born like this one is so this is a cake
a multicopter board i like the board
it's super cheat it's like five dollars
if you find it at the right place but as
you can see I've kind of had to do my
own work here this is just a piece of
wood literally I cut the piece of wood
and I drilled some holes in the piece of
wood so this could mount and stay stable
it's really important this is lined up
very nicely and it's stable otherwise
you're gonna have unstable flight okay
so anyways that's that I bought this one
this one's a lot more expensive it's
more like I think fifteen twenty dollars
but it's a lot it's square and so that's
why I was really just hoping to find it
square one so do what you want if you
want to save money this is more than
fine
I've flown this I've crashed the crap
out of this one it does one uh-huh but
anyway that's that so that's one
difference between the one I'm going to
build and ones I've built also let me
pull up the distribution boards so these
are two distribution boards this is one
here this is a this one basically allows
you to they've got bullet connectors and
this is just a simple distribution board
where basically you're going to connect
to the wires and then on the bottom side
you'll solder the wires to the
distribution board this distribution
board is actually the distribution board
I learned a valuable lesson on and that
is that carbon fiber conducts
electricity I had no idea I didn't even
think that the frames I was buying were
actually like real carbon fiber I
thought they were just like fake carbon
fiber made to look like carbon fiber but
but yeah if you have a real carbon fiber
frame understand that carbon fiber has a
resistance and that means it conducts
electricity so and it's the worst kind
because it's got like a relatively weak
conductivity and so basically the
short-circuit won't happen immediately
you'll plug in the battery you'll go fly
it outside and anywhere from like one to
five minutes later your quad is smoking
if you don't catch it quick enough one
it's a fire hazard to you'll fry
everything and you'll waste like eighty
dollars so keep that in mind so don't
don't be like me respect the carbon
fiber but anyway you'll solder basically
all the connections here and all that so
it's kind of a pain if you have a basic
board like this but again this board is
really cheap
this one's a little more expensive it
has a nice foam padding on the bottom
side so for idiots like me who think you
can just put it right on the carbon
fiber it's it's basically protected like
that also foam padding reduces vibration
but it's got these nice connectors
everything's already soldered so it
saves you some time also it comes with
this xt60 adaptor so we're going to talk
about that now for just a moment so
first of all batteries for example like
this is a venom 2100 11.1 volt battery
but it's a little older and it uses
what's called a Deans plug now this
one's you can kind of probably see it I
don't know but yeah so that's a Deans
plug and as you can see that does not
plug into that like it just doesn't work
so you want to pay attention to what
kind of plugs you're using now they do
make converters so I have three of these
I'm not about to update the battery but
they do make Dean's to xt60 converters
so you can tell it's an XT 60 by the way
that it is anyway it's the shape right
the shape and the color and all that you
can tell it also says xt60 on here but
I'm not sure if you'll be able to see
that or not but anyway that's kind of
this is like the new pretty much
everybody's using this adapter but even
if you find a Deans adapter they make
Dean's to xt60 converters so it's
totally fine doesn't really matter so
that is basically all all the basic
things that you're going to to need
you've got the frame the motors es es
propellers and go ahead and buy like
lots of propellers so you know
propellers are are really really cheap
just just buy them and have them around
because it'll probably the first like
ten times you fly you'll break
propellers just the way that is so so
frame motors ESC propellers get lots of
them a low voltage warning if it doesn't
come with one like this one this board
I'm like 99% certain that that's what
this is
I'll find out but I'm pretty sure this
comes with one so just keep that in mind
you might actually have a control board
that it literally comes with one but if
you don't have one get one you need a
transmitter and a receiver this is my
receiver and then this is my transmitter
you can buy separate
Seavers so I actually have an extra
receiver that I'll be using on this new
quad so transmitter receiver you need
and most transmitters come with a
receiver I'm just my point was that you
can you can usually buy a transmitter
that cut it comes with a receiver but if
you want another receiver you can buy
another one you need some weight to
charge balance and discharge batteries
that's tenor GTB 6b other than that
small things that you might need or you
might have around the house or whatever
you're going to need a may just grab
everything basically you're going to
need a soldering iron
okay so cheap soldering iron will do
this one's actually a Radio Shack
soldering iron so this is like vintage
man this is serious it's highly valuable
so soldering iron a way to clean the
soldering iron helping hands for the
soldering iron so if you've ever
soldered something you realize you want
like 30 hands this will at least get you
to four hands so that's nice so you want
some helping hands there you'll
obviously need some solder what you're
looking for is rosin core solder I don't
know too much about soldering myself I
just know what the internet tells me to
get and that's rosin core solder um the
helping hands iron cleaner you'll want
to have like foam so like I said like
this has like some foam on the bottom
you can usually just buy like strips of
foam and then you cut the foam and you
put that under things so like the board
you might want to have some foam this
actually has like these little rubber
stopper things that are balancing it and
that works just fine I've never really
had a huge issue with with using or with
vibration in general um so foam zip ties
just have a lot of zip ties around as
you can see like this has zip ties on it
they're zip ties all over here there's
just ties everywhere zip ties are great
get them
electrical tape there's electrical tape
everywhere here like everything it's
electrical tape I called it this
actually I call et and it's not because
it's not in reference to an alien it's
electrical tape and then uh velcro
strips so double sided that are not
double sided velcro uh like velcro
that's like sticky on one end and then
velcro
the other reason you have that is
because this you put some velcro here
you put velcro here then you have these
little like velcro straps separate it so
you've got velcro straps like that and
then to connect the battery you
literally just put the battery on there
strap it connect this to the this is my
low voltage reader connect that connect
this to the actual quad and start your
engines and then when you want to switch
it out you just literally pull these
part and switch on the batteries it's
very fast so I like having it but again
if you only have one battery then
whatever just you know electrical tape
the battery there who cares so anyway
there's that so um and then the
converters like I said you might want to
have some of those and nothing bullet
adapters these are super useful so
especially if you have um like this is
my power distribution board you take
these bullet adapters and you basically
to the wire you put the male the male
end connects to one wire the female end
to the other wire and then to connect
those you just use these little bullet
adapters connect them and you're good to
go so it's like really quick especially
if you need to flip them around when we
go to connect the esc s and the motors
you'll see what I mean when you connect
on the first time chances are you might
have to switch positive and negative on
a couple of them to make them spin in
the other direction so because some
motors spin clockwise similar spin
counterclockwise finally before I let
you guys go one more thing that you can
make the mistake of is on the motors and
the shaft and the propeller so the way
you've got quick attached and detached
propellers like these are very quick to
take on and off and so for me like the
they're literally like threaded on here
and so I just you know detach them and
the way that these stay on is literally
to tighten this you spin the propeller
this way to tighten it right so as it's
let's get tight you so so so it spins
this way to get tight so to apply torque
that way the motor spins this way right
so the motor spins this way so as the
moat when the motor is on its little
really always applying a little bit of
torque to the propeller so that holds
the propeller in place so we actually
don't need like a propeller adapter to
sit on top and clamp it on to place but
some motors basically the propeller is
totally throwing through let's see if I
can find them I'm adding trouble finding
my let's see let's open up the kit so
for example when you buy the quadcopter
you can either buy a kit you can buy
everything separately you can buy just a
frame and put everything together I
recommend getting a kit as best you can
so here's an example of a kit let me
move this over here so here this kit for
example came with ESC so these are es es
motors motors Yosi motor limb propellers
if you can tell these are first of all
these are carbon-fiber propellers if
this is your first quad don't use these
these are like nice propellers use
something cheap for a while until you're
not crashing anymore then think about
using these but anyway these you can see
they're totally like they're they don't
screw on they'd like to sit on and then
you use a propeller adapter like this
which will screw on top of that
propeller and hold it in place so
depending on what kind of motor you have
that might be a little different so just
keep that in mind
um anyway I'll put this off so that's
that anyway this is a kit this came with
basically the frame the motors and the
ESC and that's it doesn't have a control
board as far as I can recall I don't see
it in there anyway some of them will
come like with everything you need so
really just kind of look look around and
make sure it's the only thing that you
really need to pay attention to is you
want to make sure the ESC is and the
motors are together that's probably the
only thing I would always buy together
is motors and ESC s so you can make sure
they're like compatible with each other
and push enough power basically so I'm
pretty sure those are all the
requirements all the like stuff that
you're almost certain to need I might
have forgotten something so check the
list to make sure now finally I'm going
to talk about some of the optional stuff
so that stuff is basically how you could
build a quadcopter and fly it around
um I don't know what I did what did I do
with the coherence I couldn't figure out
where I put it
so let up get you to this point now I'm
going to talk about uh what we're going
to do after that so the next step is
quite literally - we want to add a
Raspberry Pi to our quadcopter so this
is a Raspberry Pi - now basically if
you're just looking at this you can see
like where is the Raspberry Pi going so
maybe we could fit a Raspberry Pi in
here right cool
but not only do I want a Raspberry Pi
but I actually want to add one more
thing and that's going to be the brick
pipe so the brick PI just sits on top of
the Raspberry Pi possibly you know
connects into the GPIO pins there right
so that's it's on top and so we can
still probably stuff that in there but
it's going to be a real tight fit so
actually what I'm going to be doing is
what's here but covered in a bunch of
electrical tape is the power
distribution board and then these what's
stuffed over here are the es C's if we
could move the power distribution board
in es es this whole space in here would
be totally open to put anything we want
it so ie Raspberry Pi and a brick pipe
and some other stuff even because the
battery goes on the bottom a lot of
people actually have this pretty clean
and they put the battery in here and I
will admit if you can put the battery in
here because the battery is like the
heaviest part you're balancing is weight
better so I may end up putting the
battery there too but the main crux of
the point here is that you want we want
to open up the space a little bit more
and the way I'm going to do that is this
is another frame but it's just tonight
just to kind of show you is there's this
is missing the top part but in the this
is the bottom part and it usually clamps
down onto these arms so what I did was
or what I'm planning to do is I bought a
bunch of these spacers okay and I'm
going to add these spacers because you
might say oh you've done it already but
no I actually haven't because these
aren't actually very sturdy because they
have spacers here but this could slide
up and down this these arms so I bought
some spacers the power distribution
or it is actually going to sit in
between these two boards the ESC s will
go on the bottom to save a bunch of
space the Raspberry Pi goes in here the
battery pack goes in here brick pie in
here or the battery pack might end up
going down here we'll see along those
lines
I know I've mentioned you know the
battery pack and flaming and all that
but this the most friends come with like
landing gear that actually aren't these
tubes these are spacers basically but
they're it's a landing gear that's
actually just like this little I don't
know the looking thing that was not tall
enough to protect my battery when I
landed so I actually added these little
spacers which are basically identical to
these so keep that in mind I added those
right so that's kind of why you want to
have a little bit of extra parts laying
around and yeah so anyway getting the
basic quad belts relatively similar from
their customizing it's a lot a lot more
complex but those are extra things that
you might want to have if you're
planning to customize so anyways who
long list is stuff a lot of topics a lot
of stuff to think about and all that
like I said the best thing I would I can
suggest is try to find a kit that has
almost everything that you need in the
kit I'll do my best to link to some kits
for examples but prices are changing so
fast that the stuff that I linked to
might not always be the best price or it
might be outrageous room I can be
available or whatever so I'll do my best
to help you guys out and that's that so
if you have questions comments concerns
whatever leave them in the Livan below
otherwise stay tuned the next video will
start actually putting a quad together
using the kit that I have we'll start
soldering some stuff and all that just
for the record if you didn't get one of
these if you if you have like a board
like this that requires soldering like
this one doesn't require the same
soldering basically I do have all at
least show clip or something of me
soldering one of these boards as well
just so you can see like both different
you know both boards also the setting up
of a control board like this is
different than the setup of a control
board like this so again we can talk
about the differences there this one has
like a nice LCD screen even
this one's really simple to set up too
so don't like don't feel bad if you want
to get this one I actually really like
this one I just wanted to be able to
have it turned and this one's just going
to this one will be compact easier I can
stuff this one in various other
locations okay anyway stay tuned the
next video questions cons below until
next time